عند تصوير اي تقرير عن اللاجئين السوريين
في اسطنبول يكون حي الفاتح وجهتنا
الرئيسيه لماذا هذا الحي على وجه التحديد
لان عشرات بل مئات المحال والمطاعم
والشركات السوريه اختار اصحابها الانطلاق
من هذا الحي التاريخي الذي يعتبر الاكثر
استقطابا للاجئين
اذا القسم الاكبر من النشاط التجاري
والاقتصادي للاجئين السوريين يتركز في حي
الفاتح وهذا يعني بالضروره عماله سوريه
كبيره تعمل هنا كعماد الذي يعمل في احد
محل الحلويات وعماد كغيره من اللاجئين
يخشى نتائج الانتخابات القادمه يعني
بس الفكره انه ما نجح الرئيس اردوغان يعني
في تخوف
بس ان شاء الله ما بصير غير خير استخدمت
المعارضه اللاجئين السوريين كورقه ضد
الحكومه خلال العقد الماضي من خلال
تحميلهم مسؤوليه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
السيئه الانتقادات تجاه اللاجئين تصاعدت
بشكل كبير خلال العامين الماضيين وقاد هذه
الحمله على وجه التحديد السياسي المتطرف
المعادي للاجئين اوميت اوز
السوريون سنعيدهم الى بلدهم والاشياء
الاخرى لا تهمك انت لست مواطنا تركيا
سنعيدك الى بلدك
مرشح المعارضه للرئاسه كمال
تعهد مرارا باعاده اللاجئين اذا وصل
للرئاسه التخوفات موجوده السبب التخوفات
حقيقه صادره من وين صادرا من استخدام
الاحزاب في تركيا لهذه الورقه من اجل
الانتخابات دائما التوجه لورقه اللاجئين
واستخدامها بطرق واساليب تعتبر لالنا
كسولين مستفزه وتعتبر مخيفه نوعا ما لماذا
نحن الحلقه الاضعف في النهايه الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان تعهد كذلك باعاده اللاجئين
الى مناطق امنه شمالي سوريا مراقبون
ارجعوا موقف اردوغان لتنامي حاله شعبيه
تريد حل مشكله اللاجئين واع ادتهم
وبالتالي اراد الرئيس سحب هذه الورقه من
معارضه
وفق القانون الرئيسي هو من يقرر استقبال
موجات كبيره من مواطن دوله اخرى يتعرضون
للاضطهاد وفي ذات الوقت بقرار اداري من
الرئيس يمكن ان تتم اعادتهم لكن بشرط ضمان
شروط الحياه الانسانيه لهم في بلادهم
بالمحصله وكما في كل انتخابات تشهدها
البلاد حاله الخوف والقلق لدى اللاجئين
تبلغ اعلى مستوياتها قبل الانتخابات بايام
فحملات الوعيد والتهديد الصادره من
المنابر السياسيه تفوق بكثير بعض
التطمينات التي تاتي على خجل من هنا وهناك
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوث
ائقيه باشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات